die impfpflicht für alle ab 18 sie kommt
nicht das ist jetzt klar gescheitert
keine mehrheit der bundestag und dabei
hat olaf scholz der kanzler diese
impfpflicht unbedingt gewollt
dieser stelle auch sagen warum ich mich
dafür einsetzen dass wir in deutschland
eine impfpflicht einführen ja olaf
scholz mit der impfpflicht gescheitert
und das das genauso kommt dass er damit
scheitert das wollte einer ganz
besonders nämlich wolfgang kubicki
mussten sie herzlich herr kubicki und
wunderschön sie haben sich schütz turms
eingehandelt sie sind wirklich gehasst
worden dafür dass sie sich an der spitze
dieser bewegung gegen die einführung
einer impfpflicht wieder gefunden haben
ist das jetzt auch für sie persönlich
ein großer ein wichtiger politischer
sieg
ich würde nicht in diese tasche greifen
weil es bei dieser frage nicht um die
frage geht wer
gewinnt wer verliert sondern es geht um
die frage für mich jedenfalls ist es
rechtlich überhaupt zulässig an dem
pflicht einzuführen und damit in die
körperliche unversehrtheit von menschen
einzugreifen wenn die damit verbundenen
ziele damit nicht erreicht werden können
meine antwort lautet klar nein und wir
kennen immer offener und intensive dass
weder das gesunde unser system
überlastet ist noch eine belastung droht
dass es kein fremdschutz gibt bei der
impfung dass es auch keine immunität
gibt bei der impfung ich selbst bin ja
gewusst hat und habe ich trotzdem
infizieren infektionsträger von daher
macht eine impfpflicht keinen sinn auch
wenn es für den einzelnen sicher
sinnvoll sein kann so wie bei mir oder
vielen menschen meiner altersklasse sich
impfen zu lassen weil damit die sorge
zumindest schwindet dass man einen
schweren verlauf hat oder sogar dem tode
anheim fällt das wichtigste argument der
impfpflicht fans unter anderem der lka
chef lothar wieler hat das gesagt sei
das eine impfpflicht verhindert dass es
noch mehr schwere verläufe gibt noch
mehr corona tote also kurz gesprochen
eine impfpflicht verhindert corona tote
das heißt wenn die impfpflicht nicht
kommt im umkehrschluss wenn das argument
von herrn wieder stimmt gibt es jetzt
mehr corona tote ja ich würde nicht jede
aussage von er wieder auf die goldwaage
legen wollen vor allen dingen weil ja
und die weltgesundheitsorganisation
gerade im gegensatz zu karl lauterbach
dem song miss erklärt hat dass zum
winter hin ist eher unwahrscheinlich ist
eine schlimmere variante wenn überhaupt
dann gibt es eher noch eine milderen
verlauf wir haben jetzt hunderttausende
von infektionen pro tag gehabt übrigens
unter geltung der masken pflicht und bei
bestehenden ganz scharfen restriktionen
mit 2g plus 2g 3g trotzdem sind aktion
nicht verhindert worden und ich kann
jetzt sagen wenn wir uns auf den
intensivstationen umschauen dann liegen
dort auch gebucht hatte und geimpfte mit
schwereren verläufen es gibt auch der
und gm steht die keine schweren verläufe
haben insofern war nicht dringend davor
politik immer mit diesem angst szenario
zu unterlegen das hilft uns im zweifel
nicht weiter nach zwei jahren pandemie
brauchen wir verlässlichkeit und bessere
daten solange er wieder nicht in der
lage ist uns überhaupt zu sagen welche
menschen in deutschland geimpft sind wie
viele chinesen sehen wie hoch der status
der antikörper in der gesellschaft ist
also unser immunisierung grad so lange
sollte er sich mit solchen äußerungen
einfach nur zurückhaltend jetzt müssen
wir das schon noch mal politisch
bewerten am ende denn wir bekommen jetzt
genau das nicht was der kanzler
unbedingt wollte und was der
gesundheitsminister auch unbedingt
wollte das hat die beiden jetzt nicht
gerade gestärkt um es vorsichtig zu
sagen
na gut wir könnten im gegenzug sagen wir
bekommen das was ich wollte
die tatsache dass olaf scholz
bundeskanzlerin ist heißt ja nicht dass
er mehr gewicht auf die waagschale legen
kann als andere dass seine stimme im
deutschen bundestag mehr wert ist als
die stimme jedes anderen abgeordneten
ein politischer prozess besteht immer da
wenn das man sich zunächst anschaut
stimmen die argumente und dass man sich
einem rechtsstaat vor allem die frage
stellt ist das rechtlich was wir tun
zulässig ist immer erlaubt da haben sie
natürlich recht nur wenn man den
anspruch hat bundeskanzler zu sein dann
hat man wahrscheinlich auch den anspruch
sich habe zumal durchzusetzen und ab und
zu mal seine eigenen themen
durchzubringen oder ja dafür habe ich
großes verständnis und ich unterstütze
ihn sonst in vielen anderen fragen aber
hier geht es wirklich um grundsätzlich
ist das ist ja der grund warum das im
rahmen einer gewissensentscheidung von
jedem abgeordneten entschieden werden es
geht um die grundsätzliche frage geht es
um gesichtswahrung von wem auch immer
von karl lauterbach oder geht es darum
dass wir unsere verfassung ernst nehmen
ich bin wie sie wissen jurist aus großer
leidenschaft und ich glaube wenn wir
unsere verfassung ernst nehmen dann darf
die frage wer verliert sein gesicht oder
wir watt seien gehe darum geht es ja gar
nicht es ist nur die frage ob derjenige
der offenbar falsch lag nämlich zum
beispiel auch karl lauterbach und der
betreut dieses thema ja nur dass es
seine chefsache sozusagen im
gesundheitsministerium ob der dann noch
der richtige gesundheitsminister ist
wenn er das zentrale thema beim
zentralen thema keine mehrheit hat
ja ich würde jetzt nicht die frage
stellen wenn er am donnerstag an wert
bekommt jetzt wird ja sonders tag
verabschiedet das eine odere nicht
verabschiedet als andere ob er dann noch
geringer ist als gesundheitsminister ich
glaube karl lauterbach hat sich in der
vergangenheit sehr hervorgetan dadurch
dass er mit vielen angstszenarien die
torschuss gesetzt hat dass er ein
tunnelblick entwickelt hat aus dem er
herauskommt ist durch den deutschen
bundestag bei der wahl der abstimmung
ich halte ihn trotzdem noch für einen
wirklich gut geeignet
gesundheitsminister in der lage ist das
ministerium vor allem auch nichts
organisieren und das erfordert mann zu
bringen nach zwei jahren waren wir auch
von dem rk ii anders als andere
europäische länder keine validen daten
und das ist das schlimmste überhaupt aus
einer pandemie passieren kann also er
sollte sich darauf konzentrieren die
daten und lage zu verbessern und dann
können wir auch sinnvolle entscheidungen
treffen persönlich am ende eines
politischen kampfes wolfgang kubicki der
sich durchgesetzt hat in dieser frage
der ganz wesentlich die allgemeine
impfpflicht ab 18 verhindert hat danke
wolfgang kubicki schauen wir mal das
kommt erst donnerstag schauen wir mal
aber ich bin sehr optimistisch danke
ganz genau sehr optimistisch ist also
die eben pflicht ab 18 weg gescheitert
und quarantäne auch weg auch diese
corona meldung ist nämlich heute für sie
wichtig gesundheitsminister karl
lauterbach gibt bekannt ab mai ab dem
ersten mai ist die korona quarantäne nur
noch freiwillig in der
gesundheitsministerkonferenz haben es
heute mit dieser situation sehr intensiv
auseinandergesetzt und sind zu dem
ergebnis gekommen dass wir zu einer
neuen ist zu uns in quarantäne ordnung
kommen müssen die also jetzige regelung
funktioniert zwar sie ist aber dauerhaft
so nicht also
notwendig und wir haben daher
beschlossen dass ab den ersten fünf
isolation und quarantäne verkürzt werden
auf fünf tage und das also die situation
und die also quarantäne nur erfolgen
sollen auf der grundlage einer
dringenden empfehlung somit auf der
grundlage von freiwilligkeit die einzige
ausnahme sind hier die beschäftigten im
medizinischen bereich dort gibt es
weiter in einer anordnung durch die
gesundheitsämter das wäre aus meiner
sicht also wenn wir noch einmal eine
große welle bekämen ohne durchsetzung
der endlich die situation wo wir erneut
lockdown maßnahmen oder beschränkungen
der individuellen freiheit schließen
mussten also corona quarantäne nur noch
freiwillig ab erster mai auch das müssen
sie heute wissen und